[Musique]
l'amitié ça se construit avec quoi avec
le temps avec des expériences communes
ou avec de la découverte
olivier je le connais depuis que j'ai
l'âge de 4 ans à l'école primaire
il faisait partie de ces enfants au
sacré caractère toujours prêt à faire la
bagarre au collège passionné de sports
motorisés
il avait débridé son scooter pour aller
plus vite on a grandi dans un petit
village on était toute une bande ça nous
est arrivé d'être complètement débile et
de monter à 4 sur son scooter
au lycée il a eu une moto en soirée
c'était lui le boute en train
vous en connaissez toussaint le mec à
l'aise plein de blagues prêt à bondir
puis il a rencontré l'amour
il a eu un enfant et sa passion pour la
vitesse s'est estompée manque de bol un
jour une voiture l'a percuté
les médecins ont été objet de lui couper
sa jambe gauche en dessous du genou il
avait 26 ans
comment at il pu retrouver son corps
suite à une telle rupture après ce choc
émotionnel et psychologique lourd qu'a
t'il eu envie de montrer aux autres et à
lui-même une fois amputée il est passé
par plusieurs états émotionnels que les
psychiatres appellent le deuil
corporelle un deuil corporels se divise
en cinq étapes
il ya d'abord la sidération souvent
associé au déni la colère la tristesse
qui peut se transformer en dépression
puis la résignation et pour finir
l'acceptation suivant les personnes ces
cinq étapes sont plus ou moins longues
le cerveau se met à disjoncter
totalement parce qu'il ne reçoit plus d
informations sur une partie du corps
jusque là présente face au deuil
le corps se retrouvent déboussolés
toutes les personnes ont des sensations
étranges plus ou moins présente plus ou
moins intenses ils seront ils ressentent
le membre qui n'existe plus le membre
devient fantôme
certaines personnes racontent que leurs
membres grossit grossit grossit jusqu'à
prendre toute la place dans la pièce est
ainsi les étouffer le vide les étouffe
la première fois que j'ai vu olivier
après son accident il était beaucoup
plus ancrés dans le sol comme s'il avait
besoin de chercher une force ailleurs
que lui même pour être juste la face à
moi sa vieille potes
j'ai eu l'impression qu'il avait honte
d'être amputé alors qu'il n'était même
pas responsables ça vous est déjà arrivé
de croiser une personne handicapée dans
la rue vous voyez ce sentiment d'être à
la fois gêné de voir et en même temps
curieux de regarder et bien là c'était
pas moi qui était gêné et curieuse mais
lui il attendait de voir ma réaction
puis il s'est assis il a soulevé son
jean et il a enlevé sa prothèse pour me
la donner j'avais cet objet dans la main
une prothèse c'est quoi un accessoire un
outil ou est ce que c'est bien plus que
ça une prothèse doit reproduire de
manière fonctionnelle un membre du corps
humain la prothèse trans tibial celles
qui se situent en dessous du genou se
compose généralement d'un manchon en
bleu d'une en voiture en jaune d'une
lame en rouge et des cosmétiques en gris
un de ces enjeux et de faire intégrer à
la personne son nouveau corps elle est
également indispensable pour son
autonomie de vie commence établi le lien
entre une personne et une prothèse
une personne c'est chaud c'est en
mouvement une prothèse s'est froissé
inerte la partie fonctionnelle permet à
la personne amputée de s'unir sur le
plan moteur à la prothèse le cosmétique
de prothèses c'est généralement une
mousse qui vient se fixer dessus pour
donner un galbe au plus proche du corps
humain c'est cet élément qui fait le
lien avec la psychologie de la personne
vous le savez tous psychologie vient du
grec et signifie la parole le discours
de l'âme alors le mot cosmétiques me
dérange un peu parce que ce mot veut
dire qui sert à entretenir la beauté à
embellir la peau mais sur une prothèse
il n'y a ni beauté à entretenir nippo à
embellir
tout est à construire en fait il faut
créer une nouvelle peau étant designer
j'ai voulu mettre à disposition son
savoir faire pour créer cette nouvelle
peau quand on a commencé à travailler
avec olivier il est arrivé avec ça c'est
un deuxième trop mal quand même
alors je parle de la peau parce que
esthétiquement parlant c'est une
prothèse performante pour cette
collaboration j'ai mis en place une
méthodologie de travail qui s'articule
en cinq rencontres
pour la première rencontre je les
interviewer avec des questions à la fois
sur les usages de sa prothèse sur ces
sensibilité esthétique et sur ses rêves
les plus fous
mais olivier en plus de porter son deuil
il avait bien compris qu'il avait aussi
en dehors un deuil et son entourage
alors il déguisait ses réponses pour ne
pas me faire de la peine
j'ai dû faire un gros travail de lecture
pour ça j'ai pris appui sur la
lithographie des chaires intitulé les
trois mondes
on voit sur un même plan trois univers
bien distincts
l'eau joue ici un double rôle
elle sépare en même temps qu'elle unit
le poisson nous renvoie au monde sous
marin
un autre moi intérieur le reflet des
arbres nous renvoie au monde aérien à
notre côté social la surface est
représentée par les feuilles fragile
posé sur l'eau comme notre peau on
remarque que ses feuilles offre une
perspective à l'ensemble de notre image
cette lithographie et comme la lecture
d'une personne à la fois un réflecteur
profondeur et surface c'est cette
comparaison qui m'a aidé à comprendre
quand olivier et en profondeur ou en
surface dans ses réponses et la prothèse
s'est révélé être un support de lecture
sur l'état d'âme d'olivier pour la
deuxième rencontre je suis arrivé avec
trois planches d'ambiance et des
matériaux associés et le tout était
d'observer olivier pour comprendre ce
dans quoi ils se retrouvaient et
pourquoi l'objectif était de donner une
direction design pour la troisième
rencontre
je suis arrivé avec des maquettes des
matériaux des objets des dessins des
schémas et on a joué ensemble à projeter
des nouvelles idées sur ces supports
toujours dans la même direction de
design en fait c'est un va-et-vient
entre l'abstraction et la faisabilité
entre les envies et les contraintes les
contraintes se réveille d'ailleurs
souvent source d'imagination
après avoir placé un peu partout sur la
table nos idées nos conceptions nos
rêves mais les deux couleurs et de
formes ça adonnait à peu près ça puis on
a fait un peu de rangement et on a
choisi qu'un seul dessein
ces matériaux on a scanné sa jambe saine
pour que je puisse reproduire le galbe
au moment de sculpter le design à la
quatrième rencontre celle essayages cela
permet de voir les modifications à
apporter pour la cinquième rencontre
je lui ai mis sa nouvelle peau ça c'est
olivier avec sa prothèse il était hyper
fier dans la rue y rouler des mécaniques
on a travaillé de concert et même si
c'est pas lui qui a sculpté modeler et
fabriquer sa nouvelle peau il était là
pour me guider
c'était à moi de le traduire pour
sublimer son nouveau lui la prothèse est
un élément endogène c'est à dire qu'elle
vient de l'intérieur
elle touche l'affect et l'histoire de la
personne
on ne peut pas faire l'impasse sur la
peau vous si votre avis perdait sa jambe
vous préféreriez le voir avec une peau
hyper réalistes ou une peau qui
considère sa différence vous allez me
dire ça dépend des usagers de l'humeur
de la personne c'est vrai à des
rendements la personne a besoin de se
fondre dans le décor et à d'autres
moments elle a besoin de vivre sa
différence
l'idéal pour certaines personnes
amputées
ça serait d'avoir plusieurs pots pour
ainsi jongler entre vie sociale vie
professionnelle vie familiale et vie
intime
on assiste à cette prise de conscience
en deux ans deux entreprises se sont
créées en france elle propose des pots
de prothèses en prêt-à-porter à des prix
vraiment abordable ça donne une vraie
respiration dans le domaine de la
prothèse en parallèle un nouveau métier
doit naître un métier que j'ai nommé le
body designer c'est un designer mais qui
doit avoir des connaissances dans le
domaine du handicap et aux reliés aux
professionnels qui tourne autour de ce
handicap car tous les handicapés ont
besoin de body design
que ce soit les enfants atteints
atteintes d'infirmité moteur et
cérébrale les personnes paralysées ou
les femmes qui ont subi une ablation ma
mère tous nécessite au moins un objet
près du corps ces objets sont
indispensables dans le quotidien des
personnes amputées et handicapées ils
n'ont pas besoin de 10 voire leur
handicap ils ont besoin de retrouver qui
ils sont dans ces objets le body
designer est là pour faire le lien entre
la psychologie de la personne et le
design de ces objets demain c'est un
métier dont les orthoprothésiste ne
pourront plus passer un orthoprothésiste
et celui qui fabrique réalisé applique
les prothèses un cabinet de prothésiste
se démarquera d'un autre part le body
designer qu'il aura au sein de son
équipe
parce que c'est le body designer kiko
construira avec la personne handicapée
sa nouvelle identité
comment créer ce nouveau métier en
adaptant les cursus de leurs thèses
prothèse parce que la prothèse de demain
ça sera quoi
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça sera un
savant assemblage entre la technologie
l'art le design et la science imaginer
l'avenir d'olivier il se réveille un
matin il met une playlist au hasard il
tombe sur un morceau qu'il adore sa
prothèse est faite de matières
électromagnétique qui réagit aux
vibrations
il connecte sa prothèse à son morceau et
sa peau se met à vibrer il peut régler
les couleurs plus ou moins chaudes plus
ou moins nuancé il peut aussi régler la
matière plus ou moins dense plus ou
moins ronde au moment où le rythme
rentrer en adéquation avec son âme il
fige la matière sa peau devient le
reflet de sa profondeur
l'amitié ça se construit avec le temps
avec des expériences communes et je
remercierai jamais assez olivier de
m'avoir fait découvrir l'immense
territoire du handicap
merci
[Applaudissements]